يد اسرائيل الطول هكذا تصف المؤسسه
العسكريه والسياسيه الاسرائيليه سياسه
الاغتيالات عمليات الاغتيال المباغته
لثلاثه من ابرز قاده سرايا القدس تفتح
الباب مجددا امام عوده نهج اسرائيل المفضل
لعقود طويله بالنسبه للتل ابيب فان
السياسه الاغتيالات هي نهجها لتصفيه
الحساب مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه وما ان
تسلمت حكومه نتنياهو اكثر الحكومات يمينيه
في تاريخ الاحتلال السلطه حتى تحدثت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه عن اعاده المؤسسه الامنيه
في تل ابيب استراتيجيه وسياسه الاغتيالات
لقاده فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
محاوله لاعاده قوه الردع التي تاكلت خلال
جولات التصعيد الاخيره في الضفه وغزه
وارضاء للجبهه الداخليه بحسب منظمات
حقوقيه فان عمليات الاغتيال ترقى الى
تنفيذ احكام الاعدام من دون محاكمه لكن
الحكومه الاسرائيليات تتخذ من قرار
المحكمه العليا مبررا قانونيا اذ سبق
انقضت المحكمه العليا في اسرائيل بان
عمليات الاغتيال هي احد اشكال الدفاع عن
النفس المشروعه ضد من تصفهم بالارهابيين
وفي تاريخ الصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
شهدت سياسه الاغتيالات ثلاث مراحل ما بين
تصعيد وتهدئه فخلال فتره السبعينيات
والثمانينيات من القرن الماضي وحتى توقيع
اتفاق اوسلو عام
1993 كانت جلول اغتيالات خارج الاراضي
الفلسطينيه اغتالت اسرائيل خلالها خليل
الوزير القيادي البارز في حركه فتح وفتح
شقاق مؤسسه حركه الجهاد الاسلامي والكاتب
الفلسطيني غسان كنفاني اما الفتره الثانيه
من الاغتيالات التي شنتها اسرائيل فكانت
بعد توقيع اتفاق اوسلو وتركزت ضد قيادات
حركه حماس مثل اغتيال يحيى عياش قائد
كتائب القسام السابق وعادل وعماد عوض الله
ومع اندلاع انتفا اقصى عام 2000 وحتى
اليوم اغتال الاحتلال المئات من القيادات
العسكريه والناشطين الفلسطينيين من ابرزهم
قائد الجبهه الشعبيه السابق ابو علي مصطفى
ومعظم القياده السياسيه والعسكريه لحماس
كالشيخ احمد ياسين وعبد العزيز الرنتيسي
واسماعيل ابو شنب وابراهيم المقادمه وصلاح
شحاده وجمال سليم وجمال منصور تختلف
اساليب الاغتيال باختلاف مسرح تنفيذها ففي
الضفه تنتهج اسرائيل التصفيه الجسديه
لقاده المقاومه اما في غزه فيعتمد
الاحتلال على الطائرات المسيره او الحربيه
يتولى جهاز الموساد عمليات الاغتيال خارج
الاراضي الفلسطينيه في حين يتولى الجيش
ووحدات مستعربين وباشراف وتوجيه من جهاز
الشباب عمليات الاغتيال في المدن
الفلسطينيه خلال السنوات العشرين الاخيره
نفذت فرق الموت الاسرائيليه اكثر من 490
عمليه اغتيال بينما تجاوزت الاغتيالات منذ
تاسيس اسرائيل 3000
[موسيقى]